yeah hello and welcome to this video
let's get a couple of games on the way
see ya tea is ready actually
again you to wait any longer here
okay
now some three plus two
if you watch this actually on the
release date of the video which would be
Friday 29th of November that is Black
Friday yeah
so that's how it's fascinating and this
Black Friday thing I mean I'm in Germany
and that never existed like a couple of
days until a couple of years ago and
then it's somehow God's got to be a
thing in Germany probably mostly YouTube
Amazon ok playing philosopher chess so
if you watch that on that Friday I will
post him another video today about my
keep it simple default print book if you
want to buy it with my signature there's
a way to do that that will be also on
today and I will also
Oh what like five to fifty something
viewers yeah okay I'll be on the front
page for whatever reason off the chest
um yeah I will awesome I want to mention
that I got um live show today at 6 p.m.
Central European Time
the German lash oh let's
yeah this variation is of course part of
my keep it simple D for repertoire and
something that you would probably get on
the board quite a lot if you played this
repertoire these Slav setups are fairly
optional and yeah this is something that
is featured
in the book by its ideas to bring the
night to a 5 which would be very
annoying given that to b7 pawn cannot be
easily protected
yeah he's currently trying to get a 5 on
the road probably Bishop d8 this idea
um the question there is actually how I
handle this
I can go Knight a5 and just pick up the
bishop hair but he is ready to play e5
interesting a bishop d8 is pretty much
forced I don't know exactly what kind of
decision yam is he's trying to make him
95
he's ready to play e5 him often bishop
g3 and f4 can be played
I wonder about this particular situation
[Music]
not so easy to say Reni if I should play
95 here or not
you
awesome I mean the move
and not actually play five
now both captures make some sense I just
wonder what is best
I think I'm going to tick with the pawn
yeah I thought that doesn't work
actually because I can take twice and
play a form
the issue is the bishop on g6
so he's blundered the bishop the
question is if he can get some sort of
desperate count to play that is possible
it's not completely
completely
plausible to do two things this because
he's only two I'm currently a little bit
uncoordinated
surprise for for winning the peace yeah
I probably bishop to have one even
though it looks a bit ugly we should
have three can tag
Ready's deform
I can also play rugae form actually that
is interesting
yeah okay for it's like a good move
maybe I can do without retreating the
bishop to have one
no not a bad choice um however I think I
can take there's nothing particularly on
lamenting about it
Knight c5 I take f7 player f4 check
yeah this is a bit better
now how do we play this
to take here and then probably push the
pawn I think I can just castle that
looks like the way to go
now I'm still covering deform and attack
v7 I'm what and what I need to do here
is I need to trade his active rook here
that would be helpful
or improve the night that is also
helpful it's still a bit of a technical
task
what is this I've got six no five pounds
five pawns
Kim
[Music]
there will go back
it's got seven yeah it's not it's not
super simple
[Music]
thing to win
you
mium wants to take it too now it's
probably not easy to stop
but I can put some pressure here against
the deep on
this 3+2 so
the time disadvantage is a bit worrisome
but would not ultimately fool me
that is surprising
it's the count
you know
let's go here I mean he has improved my
pawn structure I'm not unhappy about
that I can take now rook c7
yeah I think I can first do this
in this tempo and now I'm stopping the
counterclaim is till as these pawns are
hanging and some of them will drop now
I takes d5 coming
you know
you
you know now that's that line is a
little bit better for white just just
like that
then I think the key point of course was
a 5 when he was losing material maybe
after the capture he should play oops
I'm sorry
yes you should probably
try something else it turns out that
night xe5 works that move I didn't seem
and that means I should probably take
with the bishop right yes
so yeah this is the thing that is
actually good for black so I cannot take
f6 and I could have prevented this
scenario by taking with the bishop when
yeah rook takes is the same thing as the
game winning the piece and 97 I can play
f 4 and again f 5 is a big of a problem
a bit of a problem um yeah one issue is
here black can play you should be ADA
mediately
for this then I'm going to play this
kind of position and this is something
that analyzed in the book and is not
particularly thrilling for black and
white has just a huge space advantage
and you know and if drawbacks apparent
okay now let's go form a new game
you
it's also a double life show in German
and English
Sunday afternoon Central European Time
on time and I cannot recall if I have
the German chauffeurs or the English oh
yeah it's all easily
pound on them on the chest 24 website
I'm just 24 you can also subscribe to
chest 24s YouTube channels they are all
um stream to YouTube et pour some PT
means small and that much I know
or song probably completely
mispronounced I don't know what that is
maybe an animal
okay now
the blacks should now take and probably
play d5
but many players actually play knight c6
in this position which I never really
understand
interesting
it looks a bit odd
the idea is not unknown of course but
so teams early
it is going to force him to trade it
the end should be good on c3 yeah this
is one point and now I have to go III I
think cover that pawn
I try to go c4 in 93 in the future
c4 and then d5 probably than 93
you
yeah I really think it's much better for
to take early on on Don defore Here I am
okay yeah yeah he has d5 here actually
d5 would be a good move
yes you found that
pound is strong it's not exactly rocket
science but
silly had other options that also
but possible
[Music]
you
PRC for
yeah this actually this d5 calls into
question my whole concept because part
of this was to play d5 myself
and obviously that didn't work out so
he's a checking deform I don't want to
react to this passively so let's go see
form
taking on d5 was also possible with
group t8 didn't look right to me
I mean right for me didn't look good for
me now now I can take with the pawn here
right with 94 to come
now my night
gained a very useful tempo
[Music]
now his kind of yes - watch out the
knight on d4 is currently a little bit
loose it's under fire by Queen and
Bishop and he can barely support it
yeah I'm curious now about his move
doesn't doesn't react at all basically
yeah okay it's got to check on you too
but that's not really something good
anyway this must be right would be
strange if it wasn't
and now we are a couple of things I can
play Bishop a3
ask the Queen about what what did--what
is about to do with e7
I cannot go up d1 that is not great he's
on that
a ch3 is an interesting move
you
I'm not sure I should play a little bit
quicker
there are many lines now that lose
material for black like Nydia 3 for
example takes Bishop takes XG 7 King g7
Queen's III check picks up the peace 192
is just this is a ya trip with no return
to get an ID to check
ultimately probably has to retreat
Bishop f3 Bishop takes d4 also drops
material
you can take age three then I take
deform again I will win some material
even though this is not
decisive in terms of pure material
account
finally if he goes back
No yeah so now I can take on deform
just wonder if I got something better
just quickly checking this yeah I don't
think so so I'm going to take
and now I can simply take age three yeah
is what I meant with know I'm certainly
a lot better here
but it's not yet winning advantage
material wise
this is interesting I think I should
probably consider to play Knight g4 and
go on to the dark squares
but you know I can also just play Roxie
one let's go with 94 I doubt that he can
defend this with five seconds
yeah Knight f6 wins the Queen um yeah
the Val interesting probably I shouldn't
play that ft2 with hindsight wind c1 is
given by the engine here yeah it's
possible that I even have that in the
book that's absolutely possible I
sometimes forget stuff yeah this this is
not so great yeah
even Knight g5 seems to be a move that I
didn't see but what he played was
completely fine knight c6 and now here
this 65 is fine for black I guess
c4 I thought about
yeah I actually thought about this but I
didn't quite see what to do after 95 but
it seems that night a3 gives a white
very good compensation
[Music]
mmm angling for something like this
now this is pretty good pressure I am
that's pretty good pressure for the one
yeah so the way it was this was already
pretty pretty bad
age three wasn't even best truck 81 was
best
okay what is that what is the idea this
is the idea probably
now yeah but h3 is also winning yeah so
what's the winning okay so one game
let's go
it seemed said
this is my challenge like this I have a
bit of a lower rating requirement and
the games pop up a little bit quicker
also try this one or change 5+3 maybe I
get somebody there I don't know if I can
actually challenge multiple times at the
same like different versions at the same
time I wouldn't mind dad
that seems difficult to get a game plan
try this again okay arenal is my
opponent um yeah let's go efore for a
change
F Knight c3 in my book
I recently had a admittedly somewhat
brief look at the Italian and I felt
that this is something that I should
probably study him
little bit more
they play it so often nowadays
should be six hmm maybe this is an idea
now
don't mind if he's taking I'm kind of
making this up as I go along I really
have no theoretical knowledge him
so stop Bishop c4
looks
like
woman
I'm a junior event at some youth event
this the slow Italian but things like
that are nowadays played in Grandmaster
chess all the time
they really don't
know what to do in the in the room
yeah as the marshal and the bullion is
so so solid and therefore people have
turned to the Italian game quite a bit
yeah this is actually a nice position I
mean I have a good central control d5
it's not possible for him to play and
yeah so he wants to it seems like a fine
I actually had the idea to play Knight
age 4 to f5 so this is throwing a
spanner in the works so - same
it's not a big problem or anything
I cannot play what I wanted to play
originally okay yes so check with the
rook I guess
win takes blunders to see seven porn
now nope wanted to do this Knight to e4
and Queen to G form something like that
looks pretty attractive
you should probably consider to play
rook evade
Bishop d8
interesting
okay
plus you get rid of his somewhat weaker
bishop
and yeah successfully so
maybe I can check with the rook
I mean obviously I can take with the
rook but maybe it's actually almost
Singh idea
yeah
you
not sure that mmm
threatening much
maybe if I should think about the move
c5 in this position this is something
really interesting and something that I
could have played before and now he has
prevented it
c5 he could take because of Knight f6
maybe I should still play it actually
it's interesting but it's a little bit
loose if I take take Knight takes may
have to pawn is hanging
okay let's just prevent any night deform
and then see what happens
this one okay
you
not sure if 93 is something good
now we have transposed to a Kings Indian
structure but he's got Knight f6 Sam Ned
it's now actually not much for white if
anything
ya know I should have taken with the
Queen
that was pretty clearly better me not
better much better for white but clearly
it was the better option
mm very uncomfortable
you
no no that I didn't play well he um he
did a good job down defending this
position I think at the beginning that
must have been pretty good for white but
I didn't find anything right and he
defended as well
[Music]
yeah
you
very nice
right 44
yeah this is not nice he has his
pressure on the F file and I got no
particular
[Music]
compensation in return
I pretty much have to
offenders
came
you
only still before
you know it's it's still okay for me I'm
not in huge trouble but
expected warm
you
if I take
for he might
take taking with the pawn I don't know I
can go all the way let's take him
go all the way to be three Brooke has no
squares
Minnie can play something can play the
b-pawn yeah
and now he has to do something about it
Oh
does not do does he what is he doing
here
or am I missing something very
fundamental isn't this trapped
no that's not a cheat this is on Poisson
odd
is definitely okay
yeah
I can start this King walk but he can
play this b6 or b5 probably be six
earlier like here for example I will I
will have to take and now he's he's not
trapped I mean I think I'm fine I can
defend this pawn and this is just just a
normal ending which is probably about
equal but damn he just completely
ignored this did you forget about my
song I know probably he did okay now
another game
what is the time here like 27 minutes
and
can we play wait
there was a request to have a bit of a
longer game so what about a 10 plus 5
that would be a rapid game
played this for a long time
even got a question mark behind my
reading as it is so outdated
let's see if we get something there
fifteen plus 15 is a bit excessive
it's a bit too long for me
maybe you get this quicker actually
because of because that is a preset
button
let's try
time we wait for this 10 plus something
really wonder and so difficult to get a
game now
many players are only at 25000
I don't know if there's any kind of let
me check
chin
[Music]
let's say about 2000
anybody around okay we get one Greek
garage something recorded 46 let's see
what he's up to
it's a bit long but then it was
requested so why not
it's now a thing I do I play the Ragusan
or go for the Ragosa nor not if we play
with d5 then d5 now is a bit more
interesting so his plays playing the
London
no mainstream
line with C form
okay this is known to be fine for black
for a long time
why does essentially playing
buying a Slav defense with reversed
colors what what it's done but it's
doing the extra tempo is of course
helpful but nothing particularly
rade
what white is doing most of the time in
this kind of structure is to play the
bishop out here to see to to trade off
my strong piece
yeah okay does this you can ignore or
take I think oblique or fc8
do something on the sea foul this is
always a bit of an annoyance
interesting now how do I take this is a
very interesting question
[Music]
as BTX comes into consideration quite
heavily
you
after Bree takes the question that I
need to answer is do I manage to
favorably play C takes nc5 this is the
thing I think I do
because I want to make sense of the rook
and that can only happen if I take on
the form once and play c5 again so I
take him
it's no need to spend time or is it when
a three is actually moved where you
could spend a moment because his
weakening be told so much
see for intending to later
under B porn is not a bad move
absolutely not
the Eternity of C takes D for e-text e45
after which she will very likely take
and then after Bishop takes and very
comfortable as well
you
it's a tough call that's really tough to
decide
because there are two things that are
better for me
I'm going to do this I'm really not sure
about this she takes nc5 was definitely
also very nice
here you need to take into account that
I cannot just play group create because
he's on f4 okay
that's an odd move
I mean ooh it's just bad right by a
steady move
okay I play c5 and I don't really need
to fake a thought process yep c5 is
going to be played anyway so let's do it
this is good for various reasons it
looks at the King here opening up this
if it takes Bishop takes this is
immediately terrible and there are some
other tech technical implications now
here um if I take on d4 he will take
with the e pawn and then there's even
Bishop g5 sorry Knight h5 and
potentially Bishop g5 to consider I
wonder can
mmm is there any point in
playing Knight h5 immediately as
compared to take on d4
probably not so I'm going to take
Knight h5 Bishop h2
it threads in G 4 and F 4 then so
this surprisingly isn't so terrible
[Music]
so now h5 is maybe not the best thing to
do
but I have the simple solution Bishop to
d6 of course and this is what I'm doing
he more or less has to trade now I don't
see
hey does not have to try he can play
Bishop f2 that's nothing it's not better
or worse
okay the key thing is I want to go MOOC
p8 and basically wind upon as rupee one
is stopped and the bad thing about this
is for white as he has f3 plate which
makes absolutely no sense in this
position it just weakens when he squares
and there is no upside you can imagine
if the point is sin on f2 at least there
could be Knight f3 to e5 yeah or oops
yeah something like that and now just an
additional pretty severe weakness of the
dark squares if you imagine let's say he
takes on d6 Queen takes I might have
Queen g3 next or Queen f4 the dark
squares are terribly weak
ya know its own his turn to think he has
hasn't spent any time before this point
and it's probably already beyond
salvation does this looks like
it's more or less lost I think so
at least close to that
you
okay
not have this on the radar okay Ruby
eight what are you doing about
the b2 pond okay look at you sorry rook
a - I didn't really think about this but
he has rugae - it's true
now I can play night before that is the
most obvious thing to do yeah
or is there anything better
No let's do it
after the trade of the night
I have quit b3 I've gained this square
and he it seems tries to
trade the bishop down okay
now how do we play
I will I'd like to of course
double or triple on the B file I think
this is a good move Queen c7 that is
having a look at the F for porn prevents
any F porn
moose okay it cannot move anyway but the
main thing is that I want the rooks in
front of the Queen here if I start to
put pressure
under on the beach upon
you
YUM I can awesome
think about just covering this with f5
for example
instead of capturing
yeah I'm sure but let's take
the funny thing is that we even if he
goes rook f2 he's able to
to to cover this right I mean it's it's
it's extremely passive but you will very
likely not lose that
not lose that pawn what is funny in this
position if if you imagine now let's say
white rook wouldn't be here let's say
here and the bishop not on g3 or h2 but
on c1 this actually could be better for
white because the bishop on c1 is
completely covering this pawn and white
is able to play g4 and so on they have
been some classical examples for this
kind of this kind of thing that I always
found fascinating Wow
you
yeah I do I see the point he wants to
play King G - Bishop G 1 and so on that
is what he wants to do
I'm going to
[Music]
revoke the rook first to have to and
then I continue with something else
really not possible to make any headway
them
yeah maybe f5 is actually already on the
radar
you
yeah and stopping this not not happy
with with this development iam
I have to switch my focus sim nothing to
nothing to win under
on the B file
I should have probably not taken on see
to word plate f5
that becomes
a little bit more parent now
I want to go to H 5 H 4 is a bit of erm
is a bit of an odd move
didn't feel very necessary to
we can this even more
[Music]
now
what about
I have f/4 at the end of all these lines
you
yeah I think it works
five if he takes it I have f4
pawn takes Quincy forecheck
and I'm breaking through
yeah let's do it
you
I think I have to strike before he gets
the a to work in the game as well in the
resulting positions would always be very
one-sided but I'm not sure that I can
win and
this is definitely what I would like to
do
so after you
that takes aegyo Queen g4 we g3 doesn't
work as the rookies hanging and T I can
take on F form
so Bishop Teague's
is Queen f3 possible it looks sick but
it could work
it has to be working otherwise wireless
would be completely lost
yeah okay let's take it then
we never three yeah this is crazy I
don't have a single
a single good discovered move
a king or queen takes g5
you
yeah maybe this is the thing
let's keep the tension for a moment I'm
not threatening all that much
you
now I could take on g3 and trade trade
everything off
that could actually be quite good
because at the end if we trade every
single piece on the kingside and there
is this issue with the rook however
however what about Bishop d6
what happens after Bishop d6
I'm covering my rook on F AIDS his queen
is attacked
I don't see where this going
and this should actually win
should win
you
well queen has nowhere to go
you
yeah let's have a look at this um there
were a couple of interesting moments
yeah one is here where you have this
choice between C 4 which is young
computer likes it but um the alternative
that would be to take take and play C 5
is also looking very attractive
now this is very nice he more or less
has to take I guess and then we have
this this is nice I've got a full point
scent and just nice nice position see
Froy f3 was a bit of a shocker because
that doesn't really
doesn't do anything just weakens so c5
kind of normal bishop g3 I took it and
now Bishop d6 is a good move I think
the engine finds something better it
wants to go yeah okay we see yeah Bishop
h2 was my concern and now the engine
finds the remarkable move e5
'if I've
you should take a five and then Bishop
2h form
you
kind of see the idea I mean rookie a
disappoint probably after G for this
rookie aide right at the idea rook e8
this is crazy stuff
and now these are two hanging but if
five is also hanging and it cannot move
as he too is hanging and if you move the
King let's say let's say King G to where
the neverkey five wins right here okay
was this is a
not a complete disaster yeah
so something like that okay that is even
stronger yeah but if five is kind of a
not a very human move
okay Bishop d6 is a good strategic move
nothing wrong about it and form and now
maybe maybe I can be more precise
ninety-four worse maybe a bit too
[Music]
a bit too simplistic
I mean here 94
engine wants to play Queen c7 b7 you can
always keep the pressure on this is
maybe not the most promising way to play
even though it is of course usually
better for black now now I should go f5
definitely
this is not good
a five is better
so that after the capture no I actually
have a very convenient choice I think F
takes em F takes them all so what the
engine says now we have just a better
structure compared to the game with the
palm being here so I can actually
pressurize F or g5 is on the agenda he
has a Billy or pretty weird piece
configuration that was stronger you
should see - um I mean it's of course
better for like well it's not it's not
devastating
yeah I automatically fire before he can
play a five that was a pretty radical
decision and probably nothing the engine
likes too much yeah it's kind of yeah
again it's always somewhat better for
luck
but it's difficult to determine the the
best way
yeah h4 I think help me now Queen f7 and
the Queen comes up and now g5 must be
done now right
I would Bishop c7 is also given as good
and that's an interesting engine line by
the way here now the engine here gives
Bishop c7 we never three takes takes and
age five and it says minus one point
five and I would argue that this is
probably a draw but this is probably a
draw I don't see like winning this
position
do we win you can March the king up to a
four or you have to do some miracle g v
e5 pawn wreck this is probably a wrong
evaluation then they engineer the stock
fish engine is giving so g5 i think is
right open it up takes takes and now F
takes losses okay
best move was Queen f3 yeah that's two
actually Queen f3
then the question is do we how do we do
this how do we play g4 again this can be
too close to it could be that this is
too closed but here the winning chances
a bit better compared to the position
that we had reform I probably wouldn't
have played you form but rather move the
Queen back Queen age 7 assists on Queen
G 6 y and F takes should probably lose
after a form and think exactly with
exactly with the game Corinne takes and
now he's out of out of moves
am i actually threatening Bishop d6 now
because he has Queen III as a possible
defense
you know but Bishop Siwon is actually a
threat it's a bit ugly we should see one
but the Queen has no squares crazy it is
last year it is lost
okay so that was a good one it wasn't
wasn't a marathon game let's go for one
more one more blitz all right now this
is
this is
[Music]
yeah this was the game
with the trap Brooke
you
again one of the lines out of my book
that I did I do forget all the time I
get this and then I forget how to play
it I should really I should really
I still have the book
so and
shipping box
you
aim
here in this line blacks problem is the
odd Bishop on b7 maybe some ecig space
player comes into consideration
Ryan to
force me
to take or something like that I don't
really believe in a d6 based approach
him
you
why you six should probably be played
you
aim now how do we play this
an entirely clear to me
you
you can of course just develop
for for example but
not sure if this is the best way to do
it
taking only six looks wrong
Bishop g5 as to all it's an option just
for go for the pin
yeah let's do that
or be not worth
huge amount of time on this
you
this can be useful Wow really
are you doing there
okay so queen bee three wants to go
Queen before I guess
you
I also have the interesting idea
I don't know if this is any good
to take and play 94 that's a very
uncommon idea
you
I feel Queen a5 should be refutable like
completely refutable
you
anyway let's do this it's interesting I
am not sure if it's good but it's
interesting
you should be too we won doesn't work at
all
Bishop g7 96 the bishop here is kind of
and of stuck
you
probably can just play okay seven here
you
kay
[Music]
still has some issues too
for the night
a problem for him
a six
[Music]
you
sin f no time
I still have no time is a weird way to
phrase it
um I have I'm again it down on time
you
I don't know if you will take but it's a
pre move that I can enter
you
and I can put the bishop to D for this
is a big issue
yeah it should be for is good
you
then let's go here
you
yeah I want a pawn that's nice but
doesn't mean that I win the game
you
I can take this huh
give an old game
I really felt after queen a5 I should be
very good I'm very
it's just Queen d2 had some normal move
and like has nothing to do okay I'm
still a bit shocked that Queen d2 is
like + +3 almost point something at
least
yeah I mean what exactly is flex move
now it's not easy d6 cannot be played
and here this is just not helping yeah
this is actually very strong so Bishop
f6 is probably not the best way to play
even though it seems like I'm keeping
some advantage
95 not sure but I needed to move
something rookie 3 look good
and here now is probably just losing the
plot
you
you know I think it was I mean I could
have done better but it was reasonably
well played
okay a final game one final game and I
got to do something here
so the Sian
you
YUM we have a pretty symmetrical central
pawn structure but
my night placement only seven allowed me
to
be a little bit quicker with f5
you
before I got 96
this is strange honestly
why would white close the queenside
you
it looks very dangerous
and yeah I guess I take
and it must be pretty pretty nice
yeah you can go night h4
some other good things
of course always feel attracted to
ev3 but I think he can take it and
doesn't need to lose then
yeahmaybe night age 4 you can take and
play the f-pawn
it could still be playable for white I
mean this is definitely not good but
be playable
you
as quickly played
I get to I got you
looks
you
would be one isn't amazingly calm
I mean I'm not saying that this is the
most dangerous attack ever that I have
but it is definitely something that
would scare me and he just goes rupee
one kind of a non move
yeah I think I'll take it
it's just a huge extra bone them
you
so g4 takes
not quite winning
now if we've
a g4 now takes rook F to
yeah it should be enough
you
now this is made no it's not made
I wanted to check here and then say he
takes on age three and then Luke age 8
May but then my rook is singing
this is
[Music]
this is annoying ouch
and their window can I believe it
ruptured to King takes
just too freaking stupid I don't see it
at the end of the day
have to play some stupid ending
that is probably much better for me or
winning but still it's entirely
unnecessary
looked like I should have made on
something really really decisive
you
so I'm taking this
problem here at the end is the poor near
the b5 pawn I've got all pawns on dark
squares and he has all of them on light
squares so b5 is probably not you cannot
save this pawn I guess YouTube this this
is what I meant with a clearly better or
winning ending but it felt like there
should have been something more
bring the hammer down
you
Jim somehow
you feel I should have checkmated him
maybe f3 wasn't really good I mean here
this is a position where you can also
just strengthen the position to no end
because white has absolutely zero
counter play he has nothing on the
queenside and I can maybe just pile up
but I felt ok let's end this but it is
actually not didn't feel completely
decisive
yeah here I think he can move the F pawn
like f3 or f4 and I wasn't sure that I
really have much
you should be seven yeah that's what I
would have played or age five something
like that and then I mean white must be
worse but he's not losing
I was really surprised that he played
all those slowish moves
yeah well I can really just take
and now I should probably be a bit more
precise who kf8 but maybe it does win it
is it's really possible
because the ending is probably the best
that he can get and then it still seems
lost here of course I had a huge blunder
I thought this this and now made but
it's not made of course
the engine still thinks that this is
fantastic yeah I can take ok yes I can
take and then something like this also
is great but I think what I did should
win
it should takes us probably stronger but
this is the winning ending I think yeah
it is so it probably wasn't so terribly
played but it looked like it should be
over much quicker ok guys hope you
enjoyed it
thanks for watching